what is the boy's name Charlie middle
name ocean early ocean go boom
yeah an audible gasp well Charlie that's
an that's an ocean so you know a little
out there but as it is but the two out
there and I love the ocean it's not like
oh so idiot you didn't name him after
the ocean thought it might have been a
coincidence
yeah it's ocean if you had a great-uncle
ocean or something I don't know as
possible no or ocean spray yeah minja
cranberries yeah that was delightful
England horrible concoction
you've take that cranberry sauce out of
that can and slice it into slices what a
horrible horrible dish wait what do you
I'm sorry Ocean Spray people do they get
commercial time on this show they buy
commercial time
I love paying for these socks right here
for that high-quality sock the good
people at Ocean Spray Lola
okay so the name is ocean are you good
with the baby what I think so Emily what
a dear dear wife I have she's so
wonderful yeah you're like my dog I
started with a key okay that's mine you
know you don't have notes for a Jeff
Goldblum interview literally just says
say hello and then madness ensues that's
how it says on a car that's the magic
she's so good yeah I you know I've been
I mean I changed him a couple of times
you know you you're you're a diaper
changer you're a doll yeah yeah not
anymore I mean I changed Andy's he
change his mind but that's that's
recreational yeah but but the point
being yet yeah and you get to a certain
age where you not to do that anymore
yeah I'm very I think I'm very good he's
so sweet and he's so good and sweet I
enjoy him I love him to bits and what do
you what is this well you know what are
you doing to the baby what is this well
I know Zil him I smell him I kiss him I
talked to him I make jokes with him I
sing to him really
you brought a piece of video I've not
seen it yet but I guess this is you sort
of singing and playing with your baby
and a Jeff Goldblum sort of style let's
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]